Film Courage: What are the top three reasons
a filmmaker will be rejected by a film festival?
Daniel Sol, Hollyshorts Film Festival Co-Founder:
Well I think one, first thing something that
(I’ve been thinking about this a little
more) at times it’s not the fault of any
filmmaker at all.
Some festivals and at times we even see it
with our’s you have a story that you’re
telling that is redundant in the sense that
it’s a category that is very heavy in a
sort of area or style of storytelling.
It can be sometimes dramas.
Or it may be a sort of heavy family drama
that might be replicated by 10 other films
or maybe more that are telling a very similar
story.
Now if that happens as programmers we are
looking to program a diverse range of films
and are we going to show four, five or six
of the same types of stories and films?
And if we are only selecting 400 out of thousands
of films.
That’s going to be very hard to say yes
to that.
And it’s not fault of anyone’s.
It’s just a situation of percentages, you
are telling a story that happens to be similar
without getting into to many details of the
specific stories (of an exact story).
You know what I’m saying?
It falls under something that we are seeing
in this whole submission pool, identical stories
essentially.
Sometimes even very identical to the point
where the filmmaker takes a story that is
in the public domain and remakes a story whether
it is Stephen King or something like that
right?
And they tell that story, you might see four
submissions of the same exact movie which
is fascinating from our side.
Hey who did it better or who did it worse?
They are all different movies but they are
the same story, they are literally the same
story.
So at that point are we going to show all
four of them even if they are all great?
It’s hard to say yes to that.
We’re not going to show the same movie over
and over.
We’d had it happen where actually where
two films that are actually the same films
actually made it in.
Same stories but actually different types
of films to be made.
Different types of films but same story.
So that can happen, it’s rare but it has
happened.
Most of the time they are not going to get
in.
It’s hard to say if they are all great maybe
none of them get in.
What if one gets in?
Are we going to accept two more generally
speaking of the same story?
That’s not something you can control as
a filmmaker?
How do you know you made a film and that someone
else made the same film and they submitted
it?
That’s not something you would know.
That’s not something you can control?
So there’s an element of uncontrollability
to that.
Then there are also the percentages as I mentioned
we went from the early years (2,300, 70, 500,
1000) to know 5,000 plus submissions.
Same amount of slots, we are not increasing
the festival to 800 slots.
We’re not going to 14, 15 days.
We are 10 days.
We are around 400 films give or take give
on run time.
And five programs a day and so within that
we have different categories.
We have to fill in the blanks as to what can
fit based on genre, need and style.
So that’s already inherently a competitive
situation.
We’re talking 5 to maybe 10 percent of all
submissions will generally get accepted.
So now inherently we are saying potentially
90% may not even make it.
We’re not even talking about scores, we’re
not talking about anything else.
I’m talking about just the numbers there
so that’s the honest portrayal of the competition
nature.
And now outside of that we get into what is
wrong?
Now we are looking at any of the potential
flaws whether it is technical stuff, technical
issues whether it’s the obvious things of
poor jump cuts or a boom mic in shots (obvious
things).
Any of those things, that’s it.
That’s kind of an automatic rejection of
sorts.
Basically you are eliminating yourself in
that sense just because of those errors or
edits.
So there is that.
Then you get into how is the acting?
How is the storytelling?
Then if some of them are really poor you are
going to have a lower score you are going
to get reject.
You are not going to make it.
And again, that’s the standard baseline
of our festival at this time.
I don’t know about other festivals.
Maybe there are less submissions or more slots
and other things that they have going on.
But when you look at that aspect of it some
of those elements can make it automatic for
us so you are sort of rejecting yourself in
some sense.
If some of those areas are flawed and then
there are some of the technical aspects those
things are sort of automatic.
Then you get into after all that what are
we looking to program?
How is the storytelling?
Is it unique?
That’s a big thing.
We are looking for at times watching so many
films our review team and myself watching
so many films it’s always exciting and something
desirable that a film and a story whether
it’s outside-of-the-box or different, stands
out in a big way.
That can be a lot of things whether it’s
very graphic whatever or a unique style of
storytelling or visually very different or
whatever that may mean.
But that’s a big deal.
Because you look at all these films and if
something rises to the top you say “I’ve
never seen this before?
This is very unique.”
And we’ve never seen this before.
We’ve seen all these films that’s something
that is obviously going to weigh on our minds.
We’re not going to forget that whether it’s
very graphic or whatever.
So I guess a long-winded way of saying this
is try not to be forgettable, make it unforgettable.
Make it something that just wows everybody
watching.
Where you walk away saying “Wow, I can’t
believe that film.
That was amazing.”
Because there are many stories that I guess
are playing it safe where the filmmaker or
storyteller is not really trying to push boundaries
or not trying to do something different, maybe
it’s just another filmmaking style.
Maybe there is just a lot of two-shots.
Now I know there are budget restraints of
course but within that you have to be creative
and show your style.
If it’s not how is that going to stand out
against a crowd of all these films.
If you don’t, your chances of being accepted
at that point become very, very low.
The numbers game is there, it’s very difficult.
So without talking technical stuff, the big
when films are too (for lack of a better word)
“Vanilla” you’re shooting yourself in
the foot (for us at least).
Definitely we’ve seen so many films, if
nothing stands out about it how is it going
to be unforgettable for us?
If it’s not unforgettable, then we are just
probably just going to forget it in a sense
right?
So that’s important.
Film Courage: Do you think people are taking
less risks or more risks in terms of the storytelling
aspect?
Sort of being these agent provocateurs, putting
stuff out there that is like “Whoah!”
Or some people are going to be really offended
by it.
Or do you think it is less so?
Have we become so sensitive?
Are we too P.C.?
Daniel: Maybe?
Well that’s always tough to say.
Because we see a lot of stuff that’s not
stuff, so I’d say no then.
But then we are sort of living in this new
age of being checked online (PC culture) of
“Don’t say that, don’t say this, don’t
do that.”
Of course we know there is this online battle
going on where it is cyberbullying or mob
mentality of people jumping on people for
saying the wrong thing.
I still don’t think that plays much into
the films.
I still think people are trying to push boundaries
and tell really great stories and share what
they believe in and share their vision and
style because again this also goes back to
what is shorts (always were and still are)
in some degree a calling card.
You are trying to say “Hey, look at me world.
This is what I can do, I’m showing my ability,
this is the restraints I’m up against.
This is how much money I have, I’ve only
got 10 grand, this is what I can make with
it and I can kick-ass film.”
Well if that’s what you’re trying to do
that, if you are making a seven minute short
that is a drama that we’ve seen before retold,
a certain story that has been done many times
by many filmmakers and there is nothing original
to it, you’re not going to see many acceptances
to it.
So you really want to see people take a chance
whether it is something that is provocative
or adventurous or just out there or it is
political or something that is trying to make
a stance or a stand or a strong point.
You’ve still got to try to show that voice,
you’ve got to do it.
All that said though some people do want to
make what they want to make.
You have to make your film, you can’t try
to make something or be something you are
not so there always is that.
But there is always how you tell the simplest
of stories, how well you do it visually, how
you showcase your abilities is what it’s
about because we are trying to showcase what
we feel are the best films in the world.
That’s the goal, that’s the idea.
So if it doesn’t fall into that or it doesn’t
feel like it belongs there or it’s that
exciting why are we going to put all of our
chips on it or really push it all forward
and showcase and say this is what has to be
accepted.
These other ones got rejected, you take the
place of that film.
You have to convince us.
Make us say “Why?”
So that’s part of it.
Film Courage: There was one film that I can
still see it to this day.
It was about a woman who had been assaulted
and she ended up having a child, loved that
child and the child finds out that it’s
a product of assault but I mean that film
was unavailable and I realize that some people
[filmmakers] would be very scared to do that
[topic] especially today.
But I thought it was amazing.
I know you guys have shown some things that
really push boundaries but there are reasons
for that and they are really amazing.
Daniel: For us it has been a joy and we are
in a position where we have the opportunity
to dictate what we want to do with the festival,
with the style, with everything, parties,
events, whatever part of planning the event,
whatever gets screened, it’s exciting to
obviously have a say in something in this
world right?
Where we say this is the best way to do this
and we believe in this and we can do that.
With that comes opportunity and also responsibility
to try to do the best we can with it.
And if we are giving a stamp of approval.
We are sort of trying to be as many festivals
believed to be the gatekeepers, saying this
is what we need to show the audience.
This is what you need to pay attention to.
Hollywood look at these filmmakers and these
films because this is what we believe are
the best of the best, what we believe you
need to look at, these are the films that
you need to pay attention to.
That’s what we’re doing.
We are shining a light on these films.
Obviously we are saying these ones, come take
a look at these, the other ones didn’t quite
make it (this is the reason or whatever) but
these are the ones we believe in strongly
and you have to come see these movies.
This is a responsibility that we also have
to take seriously, not just throw up anything
on screen because we owe someone something
or something.
That’s not what it’s about.
I think the more films and filmmakers are
pushing those boundaries.
A lot of films are doing like Sundance and
they program a lot of stuff that you see over
the years has also pushed boundaries, have
been very unique and aggressive in their storytelling,
their styles and not pulling back or holding
back for fear of what people react to or what
they will say.
Especially if there is something like a voice
you want to really share, what you have to
say, what you believe in, it doesn’t make
sense to be restrained or pulled back just
based on fear of reaction or what people might
think of you or something.
That’s not going to work and if you do that
your chances of being that many festivals
or any are now very low at that point.
Yes, you’ve got to tell the story you’ve
got to tell but that also means if it is more
of a film that doesn’t require that kind
of…it’s not a provocative story or things
like that.
It can be more of a simple kids film or something,
that’s fine.
But if it’s the opposite or it’s supposed
to be this very provocative story, don’t
also pull the curtain back or pull back a
bit.
I’m trying to think of a quote that I saw
recently, it was dealing of that same subject
of when it came to a film…it was retelling
a war story and they were saying there is
responsibility to not pull back on how aggressive
and awful that is.
If you are not showing what that really is
you are doing that disservice, the people
think “Oh this is okay.
This is not that bad.”
You can’t walk away feeling that way.
That’s not what we should be portraying
as a situation of showing what it means to
be in war.
War is violent, awful, terrible and sad.
To make that feel like it’s not, that’s
a disservice.
That’s something that I think people should
really keep in mind and that’s something
I’ve always kind of thought of when I think
back to that quote.
I forget, I can’t actually remember the
exact quote, so I’m paraphrasing someone
of something I saw recently.
And I remember it stuck with me in a documentary
I was watching.
It’s very important to show how awful things
like that can be and if you’re telling that
story, not tell it in a PC way to make sure
it is what it’s supposed to be and it is
aggressive and things like that or whether
it is violent or sad or depressing and not
make it less depressing and not make it less
depressing.
You mentioned the thing about assault, like
don’t make that be something that is not
awful or sad or make it feel like it’s just
okay.
Then that’s just doing total disservice
to anyone who has ever been a victim of anything,
that’s very important to not have it be
the case so the long-winded answer is just
make sure to go all the way.
Film Courage: And the filmmakers spoke afterwards
and they went into…I won’t give away too
much…hopefully we can put a link to it at
the bottom of this video.
It was amazingly done and I went up to the
filmmakers afterward and thanked them because
it was an incredible story.
And although they were trying to show that
this mother loved this child, they had to
go to certain places that might make certain
people a little bit uncomfortable.
Daniel: And challenging for those actors involved
in the project.
And anything worth telling, it needs to be
that and it’s exciting when you see that.
For us, it’s exciting, like we have a chance
to actually show this and let the story be
told and give it sort of a life if it’s
a world premiere and it’s like we get to
show this to the audience and this is the
work they’ve put in and the chances they’ve
taken and now we get to showcase that.
That’s pretty cool and obviously something
that we’re able to do here.
This is part of the blessing of being able
to do this work is showcase films like that
giving them their first chance or whatever.
Of if they’ve shown their movie 20 times
already and we’re like the 21st screening.
But we’re getting a chance to show it to
our audience and another audience can see
it and that’s awesome so obviously we don’t
take it for granted.